thank you very much for the introduction
thank all of you for coming to listen to
me talk about some of the work we've
been doing for the last couple of years
and thanks to the conference organizers
write this sort of thing is awesome but
it takes a ton of work and I'm always
really appreciative so I just want to
kind of frame the talk I'm gonna give
here two years of Asian bandits for
e-commerce we're gonna talk about a
little bit of math actually a fairly
simple mathematical machine learning
model and then what I really want to dig
into for a lot of this talk are some of
the user experience issues you can run
into and how you might try to resolve
them for you know trying to sell a
machine learning model even a relatively
simple one that we'll play with here two
non-technical people our customers are
marketers they're not statisticians
they're not engineers so as some of the
how you take a deceptively simple model
and it turns into a lot of interesting
user experience problems is what I
really want to focus on here today so a
little bit about me I won't dwell on
this for too long that's I got a great
introduction just you know if you want
to tweet at me or email me if you have
questions at all here are some places
you can find me on the Internet
I'll flash some of that up again at the
end about Monty it's a this isn't gonna
be a commercial we won't get too deep
into the weeds on our company but it's
good to have some context to know kind
of what product space we're playing in
here right so we were founded in 2008 as
a web optimization software as a service
company targeting mostly e-commerce
right so for a long time we have been
selling a be testing tools think about
you know a lot of you are probably a
little more familiar with Optimizely
Optimizely more geared towards
enterprise customers right whereas
Optimizely is a little more kind of
lower end of the market fairly cheap
subscription that even you and I could
afford for our websites if we really
wanted to we're a little more mid to
upper end of that same market and as an
idea of scale right so we saw about five
billion page views and 4.1 billion
dollars in revenue cyber week last year
and we're gearing up for even more this
year so we get to see a lot of data from
some of these retailers a lot of what
you're probably familiar with and how do
I get my boss to pay for me to come to
these events we're hiring we're hiring
software engineers at all different
levels down in Philadelphia so the the
link on this sign is no longer correct
the right link is down there so if
you're in
if this sort of stuff piques your
interest feel free to reach out and I
will put you in touch with the right
people with a with a warm introduction
and so kind of as background like I said
we're focused on making a be testing or
were focused for a long time I'm making
a be testing accessible to non-technical
marketers meaning you don't need a
software engineer to implement the test
and you can kind of run it yourself in a
point-and-click interface so you know
what do we let people specify who do you
want to run this test for you want to
run it for people who are visiting your
website on their mobile and what do you
want to do so you want to take the
homepage hero which for those of you who
aren't familiar with EECOM lingo that's
the big big-ass banner on the homepage
of every e-commerce site you see that's
called a hero and add a menu with some
categories beneath it and when do you
want to do it and what do you want to
measure about it you're trying to use
that to optimize conversion rate so
we're really focused on making kind of
web optimization accessible to
non-technical marketers and you know we
try to make statistic success accessible
to non-technical marketers also here's
how we show the ability to interpret an
a/b test I won't dwell on this too much
but we're really just trying to uh to
make this a little more accessible
trying to make it easy our design
philosophy is make it easy to make the
right choice for people who don't
understand statistics a little bit about
this talk I'm a big fan of Jupiter
notebooks this talk is actually rendered
from a Jupiter notebook you can see it
linked here on github if you're
interested in this taking the code
running it I've tweeted a link to this
this both the slides and the notebook
and my Twitter handles just add austin
rockford feel free to download it run it
there's actually lots of details links
in hidden cells that don't get rendered
to the slides of supplementary
information if anything piques your
interest so i just want to give a little
outline here so web optimization what's
it's kind of intellectual statistical
foundation a be testing where do multi
armed bandits come in how do we
implement bayesian bandits which is
really cool
some counterintuitive things that happen
there and then some more
counterintuitive things that happen in
terms of bias in bayesian bandits
so a/b testing quick crash course are
all familiar with randomized trials of
some sort right you have an orange
button and a blue button you want to
decide which is gonna make you more
money so what do you do you show 50
percent in air traffic each color for a
while and you do a statistical
hypothesis test to decide which was
better in the end there's lots of
subtlety to this Emily Robinson I don't
know how many of you went to her talk
yesterday gave some great guidelines for
how to run good a/b tests I've been
doing this for six years and I learned
some new things from her so I'm not
gonna dive too deep into how you do this
well but there are great resources out
there and so what's the a be testing
machinery that a lot of the industry
uses like really really common
especially in software as-a-service
tools what most people still use you
know the good old null hypothesis
significance testing that our good
friend Ronald Fisher came up in the
early 1900s for agricultural experiments
and so you know kind of how we went down
this journey towards Bayesian bandits
was thinking what's the difference
between an e-commerce website and an
agricultural experiment in England in
the 1900s well one big one is that we
have real-time analytics now right an
agricultural experiment you need to wait
a whole growing season to collect your
data right you're not really worried
about analyzing real-time data when
you're performing you know split blaat
experiments and real-time analytics is
great right streaming analytics has
emerged over the last ten years awesome
technology where are some of the things
that's really good for it's really good
for monitoring right from both like a
DevOps perspective are our systems up
and running and like a you know if you
think about e-commerce even a marketing
ops perspective like did that change I
rolled out break my checkout flow and
now I'm making no money and I better
roll it back fast right so it's really
good for a lot of things that happens
more often than you'd think but what's
it really hard for it's really hard to
marry real-time analytics and a be
testing right if you have an a/b test
where the statistics are updating in
real-time what value does that buy you
other than gee whiz how do you get value
out of that
if you still need to wait for a while
for something to become significant so
our goal here in implementing these
bandits is to kind of close
loop and make real-time analytics which
are very practical for a lot of other
purposes valuable for the a/b testing
and web optimization industry here's a
great blog post about some of the issues
if you try to kind of apply your
standard a/b testing machinery to that
stuff let's see if this will play some
sound so that Simpsons quote I think
kind of accurately summarizes how I tend
to think about the naive application of
real-time analytics to a/b testing right
it's really easy to get into streaming
data problems it's really easy to
inflate your false positive rate it's
really easy to make bad decisions with
partial data so real-time analytics are
great for a lot of things but if you
apply them naively to a/b testing it's a
great way to get the wrong answer faster
so what can we do about this well you
know sequential testing is great Abraham
Wald kind of came up with the basics of
this during World War Two he's the guy
that said put the armor where the the
bullets aren't where the planes come
back right and so if you're in World War
two when you're doing quality control
and ammunition right you want to fire as
few bullets as you can while still being
sure for QA purposes while still being
sure that the lot meets your standards
right in terms of defects so he'd kind
of developed that that's a great step
but I you know we can do better people
like to optimize faster than that so
what we're gonna talk about today is not
sequential testing which is kind of
porting that a be testing paradigm that
null hypothesis significance testing
paradigm to sequential data we're gonna
talk about sequential optimization and
as I said in the introduction I'm a PI
mc3 dev so I like all things Bayesian so
we're gonna take a Bayesian approach to
a B test
sequential optimization here that's
called a multi-armed bandit right who
here is kind of generally familiar with
the multi-armed bandit problem'
algorithm great I mixed about 5050 so
I'll give a quick introduction imagine
you like this lovely little cartoon
octopus walk into a casino and there's a
bunch of slot machines in front of you
right one-armed bandit says they're
called
and you don't know their payout rates
you want to determine which of them pays
out at the highest rate right but to get
information about the payout rates you
need to give each of them some money to
see how much it pays out right so how do
you balance spending money to learn
about the payout rates of each machine
with playing the one that you think is
best to make the most money back that's
kind of the exploration exploitation
trade-off that's fundamental to the
multi-armed bandit problem and so
basically I've just stolen this graphic
from our marketing materials actually
whereas what traditional testing you
would show your color buttons 50/50 you
know blue and orange until you hit
statistical significance or really your
predefined trial threshold but that's
sometimes hard to get marketers to do
and then you promote the best one to
100% right and the basic idea to
illustrate how these bandits work is
that they will gradually start
allocating traffic as you get partial
information right so maybe two days into
your test your real-time data gathering
you are able to allocate 60% of your
your samples to the blue button because
you think it's probably better but
you're not sure enough to put a hundred
percent to it right so the multi-armed
bandit problem gives a principled way to
take this blue top curve to kind of
gradually adjust as you reduce
uncertainty until you get to that same
result and then all this blue area in
the middle here is extra money you've
made extra clicks on your banner extra
time reading your articles whatever it
is you're interested in solving for so
that's a crash course in multi armed
bandits now let's get down to the
practice and we're going to get to some
Python soon right this is a PI data
conference I just needed to set the
stage so what are the four ingredients I
tend to think of in every multi-armed
bandit system we need to observe data
from the real world right you need to
know some partial information if you're
gonna act on it you need to use that
data which is noisy right those slot
machines payout at a certain probability
not regularly each time to update your
information your beliefs about the world
do you see how I quickly jump to a
Bayesian approach here
you use that information those beliefs
about the world to predict future
performance that's just a little bit of
math and then you use those predictions
of future performance to decide where
you're gonna spend your money next how
many people you're gonna show the blue
button versus the orange button in the
next time slice right then showing the
people those buttons generates more data
and this loop continues alright and so
the right hand side here I've just
called that math we won't spend too much
the left hand side that's reality I show
people a button and they buy something
or they don't right and so our job here
to understand how these systems work is
to fill in that top arrow and that
bottom arrow so like I said taking a
Bayesian approach here we're gonna use
the top arrow as Bayes theorem right go
from data to information about the world
and so here for the purposes of this
talk and things get more complex in in
kind of a real product we're just gonna
focus on a binary outcome did someone
buy or not did someone click or not
whatever so we're gonna use a beta
binomial model here right so not a ton
of math in this talk just a little bit
here's a basic beta binomial model with
a uniform prior a really nice thing
about a beta binomial model is when you
get observations this is a conjugate
system right we can know the posterior
distribution explicitly I can write down
a formula for this so now that we've
gone from data to information how do we
go from predictions of future
performance to acting on predictions
this is really cool really elegant
there's this concept in the Bayesian
bandit community actually from before
the term bandits were coined in the
1920s called Thompson sampling which
says if my model believes there's a 60%
chance the blue button is better than
the orange one show the blue button to
60% of people in the next time slice and
an update and move on if there's a 70%
chance that our model believes the blue
button is better so 70% of people the
blue and 30% the orange what's really
nice about this it's really intuitive to
explain to non-technical people right if
you asked a non-technical person to come
up with this system that they might kind
of guess at that right it's a lot easier
than like a UCB out rhythm where you're
like well I take
this Hopf ting bound and I add a
confidence interval to it and I choose
the one that's biggest it's right so
this is really intuitive and marketers
kind of really glom on to this it's
actually how they interpret p-values
those probabilities that something is
better or worse so it's you know if we
can move our definitions of the systems
we're working with in line with their
intuitions that's a lot easier than
changing their intuitions so you know we
write down the formula for this in our
simple beta binomial system and crap we
don't need to dwell on this too much but
that integral has no analytic solution
you can prove so this is a great idea in
theory really really elegant theory and
like I don't know how to use it in the
real world so when I don't know how to
evaluate an integral what's the first
thing we try well you know we're pretty
good at this we can do some em you know
Markov chain or excuse me just Monte
Carlo simulations right so here I've
drawn two posterior distributions to
kind of illustrate this integral we
actually want the integral of this kind
of joint probability distribution above
that vertical line so what can we do
there we can draw points from this
distribution and count the ones that are
above the line right that's actually
quite reasonable it's like the simplest
thing you can do to approximate an
integral you can evaluate great and so
in this case with some fake data I see
that there's like a 25% chance that
variant a is better than variant B I'm
gonna abstract from button colors to a
and B of the a B testing right so in the
next time step I would show 25% of
people a and 75% of people be cool not
so bad
well what's the real problem here the
real problem here is that this and
there's a timing cell in the background
that I should have exposed if you look
at this notebook this took like I think
I generated a thousand or five thousand
samples here this took like 20
milliseconds that's like not that long
in the time scale of scientific
computing right but the way Mauna Tate
operates is as a JavaScript tag on a
website that changes it as it loads and
a 20-second stutter and your web page
load time is noticeable in terms of
machine learning especially if you
encompass all of the other web
web machinery that needs to go on around
that right so our prediction budget is
about one to two milliseconds so 20
milliseconds is not going to cut it
because it's gonna cause flicker on our
clients websites and that loses you a
lot of money it's not acceptable user
experience so how do we get around that
well if you can't go back and think
about really the basics of Monte Carlo
simulation for calculating integrals
what does the fact that this average
comes out to the integral rely on it
relies on the fact that each point has
the right probability of being above or
below the line right so each point has
the probability we want of being above
or below the line and we average all
those estimators to calculate that
probability so what can we do we can we
can take one random sample and if it's
above the line we show them B and if
it's below the line we show them a and
we'll have a signed with the write
probability without having actually
calculated the probability that's really
cool this is like the fundamental
mathematical trick of Bayesian bandits
that makes them scalable for web
applications really interesting every
every now and then for a couple years I
would wake up and have to reconvince
myself that this worked right it's
really kind of counterintuitive for what
I go crap did I just break a lot of
webpages I finally convinced myself I
don't have nightmares about it anymore
moved on to other math nightmares but
it's really counterintuitive and really
neat once you wrap your mind around it
so this is kind of the fundamental
mathematical trick we're using here and
so I'm gonna move pretty quickly through
the code here since my nice setting the
stage took longer than I expected but we
want to simulate some of these bandits
now right if we want to get our hands on
how do some of these user experience
challenges arise let's run some
simulations on known situations to see
so here's a simple implementation of a
beta binomial distribution and give it a
prior you can sample from it you can
update a given data to get its posterior
it's just the the Python implementation
of that math here's an extremely simple
like 12 lines or something python
implementation of a Bayesian bandit you
give it to posterior one for variant a
one for variant B you can update them
with data as they arise you tell it Oh
I saw a purchase for the blue button and
will update that posterior and here it
does Thompson sampling right if the a
posterior sample is less than the B
posterior sample show B right okay so
this is like the minimal minimum viable
implementation of a Bayesian bandit so
let's simulate this guy let's see what's
gonna happen so I'm gonna set the
parameters here right the great part
about simulating systems is you control
everything so you know the outcome you
expect right so I'm gonna say the the
reward rate for variant a is 5% in the
reward rate for variant B is 10% right
if our things doing its job it should
send most of the traffic to variant B
because it has twice the reward rate
fast this is like a good sanity check
right so here's some code to simulate we
won't dwell on it too much and hey we
get what we expected right the track the
the graph to look at is the one on the
right here which shows traffic to
variant B on the y axis right remember
that's the one with the 10% reward rate
and we see that that gets pretty close
to 100 pretty fast right so we are
identifying the better performing one
the one that gets us twice as many
purchases and we're allocating web
sessions to it pretty fast so this is a
good sanity check on the left you can
actually see this compared to the reward
rates for a and B due to noise right due
to the stochasticity of the rewards you
can get a higher reward rate than the
expected reward rate for variant me this
is good but one simulation of stochastic
systems doesn't really tell us about
their behavior right so let's simulate
it a hundred times so we can put kind of
intervals around this so we'll simulate
this a hundred times so we can get a
confidence interval and average is right
that that first one was pretty
aggressive it optimized pretty fast you
can see the average allocation on the
right hand side the variant B goes to a
hundred but a little slower and the
average reward rate across all these
hundred bandits gets pretty close to the
variant B reward rate so now let's get
into some of the counterintuitive things
here a little a little close to five
minutes left so let's let's start to get
to some of the meet you
the counterintuitive stuff who here is
familiar with the practice of a a
testing right quarter s third ish a a
testing is when you run an a/b test
where the two variants are the same and
if you're not familiar with the web
optimization industry you would think
why the hell would you do this well the
answer is you don't trust your vendors
you should never trust your vendors
right they're just trying to take your
money and deliver as little as possible
that's like a lesson of life
an AAA test is like an integration test
for your a/b testing vendor right if you
are looking for a p-value of less than
5% and your AAA tests are significant a
lot more than 5% of the time their
statistics are off and maybe you
shouldn't trust them right so people
think of this as calibrating their a/b
testing vendors so a really natural
thing to do is to run an AAA bandit and
so here we have an a a bandit where I've
swapped out be rate for a rate and hey
what behavior might you expect you would
in an ideal world be near 50/50
allocation to each variant right a would
get 50% B would get 50% and we see the
averages there right right around that
50% line but like can anyone spot
anything weird here
the confidence interval is wide and it's
not shrinking right that 90% confidence
interval is wide and it's not shrinking
in regular a/b testing if this was like
the p-value I would expect that or the
test statistic so the right statistic
that I'm blanking on right now the
central limit theorem tells me that
should decay like 1 over the square root
of n right so this is really
counterintuitive if you're used to a be
testing let's look at some of the
samples that we use to calculate those
intervals man they're wandering all over
the place this is really
counterintuitive the first time I
simulated this I was like now there's a
bug in my code I rewrote the code from
scratch and I found it again that was a
good sign that I should you know dig
deeper the bandit is trying to optimize
the number of rewards you get how many
purchases you have right it's not trying
to control for false positive is trying
to get you the most purchases well when
you're showing both the red button and
the blue button as a and B every single
configuration gets you the same number
of purchases
because every single configuration leads
to the same user shopper experience
right now market or user experience
shopper user experience this is really
counterintuitive this causes people to
not trust you so there's various ways
you can combat this that I'm not gonna
get into too deeply so why do we like
Bayesian things Thompson's sampling is
intuitive it's kind of how marketers
would like this to work randomization is
makes online learning algorithms more
robust against delayed feedback and I'd
like to say marketers are natural beige
ins if you ask a marketer to interpret a
p-value of 0.1 they will say that means
there's a 90% chance that the experiment
is better than the control so like I
said let's just bring our math in line
with their intuitions instead of trying
to change their intuitions when like I
can stand up here and if I try to define
a p-value now I might get it right on
the spot so one last thing in the last
two or three minutes that I've got here
I'd like to talk about another
counterintuitive property of the system
is bias right so everyone's familiar
with bias and variance from machine
learning right bias is is the average
close is the average of your estimator
the is the expected value of your
estimator the parameter you're trying to
estimate variance is how spread out
those things are this is a nice
illustration of the four different
situations you can be in so let's go
back to that 10% 5% simulation where
there is a difference and variant B is
better and let's look at the empirical
reward rates that we observe so this is
the observed reward rate in blue and
green solid versus the known true reward
rates that are dashed who sees something
weird here the observed reward rate for
blue the worst variant is not the actual
reward rate there's biased down this is
another counterintuitive thing about
this stuff that I learned by simulating
do two questions we had about deploying
these products why does this happen
well imagine right the world is
stochastic imagine that the worst one
kind of just due to random noise over
performs early what's gonna happen the
bandits going to give it more samples
which is gonna cause it to regress to
the true mean faster if the if the worse
variant underperforms early the band
that's gonna give it less samples
because it's gonna think it's much worse
and it's gonna regress to the mean but
more slowly right so over estimates and
the worst in the true worst variant are
punished faster than underestimates and
you can see here that the upper
confidence interval shrinks faster than
the lower confidence interval so this is
what causes that to be biased downwards
and what can we do we're really good
actually at counteracting bias using
pools from causal inference so let's
take a stab they're kind of the simplest
thing you can do for causal inferences
inverse propensity weighting so let's
just try it for the sake of this talk
what does that do it takes the
observations and instead of just
calculating their empirical mean it
includes a factor for how likely that
treatment assignment was right the
bandit is changing the world by using
past data to inform future treatment
assignments it's kind of actually a
machine for creating bias
counterintuitive again but once you
think about it not at all but
counterintuitive to come from an a/b
testing background so let's implement
this and what's that bottom probability
that's exactly the Thompsons sampling
score so this is expensive to calculate
but we can do it especially offline and
you don't need to calculate this at web
page load time this is like an ETL job
and hey when you use this bias corrected
measure you do get unbiased estimates
they're noisy cuz I didn't do enough
simulations there but you get the idea
now what's fundamental in machine
learning
I have lowered the bias of this
estimator so I must have increased its
variance all right so it's important to
think about the user experience impact
of increasing the variance of that
estimator right we wanted a better user
experience so we eliminated the bias but
we must have increased the variance and
hey we sure did if I compare that the
confidence intervals for the biased and
unbiased estimators the unbiased the
unbiased estimator has much larger
confidence interval this is fine but
like marketers don't care if I show this
to a marketer they'll be like what the
hell are you doing to me what am I
supposed to take from this guy
they're actually very nice people
this causes no uh violation of intuition
the intuition is that the variant with
the highest were observed reward rate
should be seeing the most traffic
assigned from the variant that's like an
intuitive thing when marketers look at
an analytics screen and don't see that
they Firebug tickets um rightly so
rightly so now this intuition can be
violated sometimes for good reasons and
well functioning systems do just
stochasticity but if you look for the
naive estimate and the inverse
propensity score estimate how often this
intuition is violated it is triple with
that inverse propensity score estimate
so the way to think about the user
experience of that increased variance is
how often does it violate their
intuition so what I've kind of hoped to
get to here and I want to leave some
time for questions is deploying fairly
simple algorithms right that algorithm
that Thompson sampling made a binomial
model I described is not very intense
can lead to really unexpected user
experience challenges and it's really
important to think about them not from
the data scientist perspective but how
would my user think about this challenge
they don't think about it as a wider
confidence interval they think about it
as how often is my intuition violated
and I want to file a bug ticket so those
are kind of my two big things here with
this as a little Bayesian case study so
thank you all for listening to me up
here jump and shout about math a
reminder that we're hiring and if you
want to get in touch with me at all
either you know ask questions chat in
the hallway or you can shoot me an email
or tweet at me so thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
so I like to run principled frequentist
AP tests so I choose my significance and
my power I do my power analysis and it
says run your experiment for this long
and you will have an answer at the end
so one question I have about Thompson
sampling is that it seems like the
experiment never ends
yeah when yeah when do I that's a great
question and so there's a bunch of
things you can do there that actually I
think apply to different marketing
situations right so if you take your
frequent test a be testing you do your
power analysis it's going to tell you
that a lot of especially one-day
promotions small things are hard to
optimize so that's actually a great
situation for this that we find a lot of
our customers use for things where
they're a be testing methods are not
going to reach significance especially
Black Friday Cyber Monday stuff like
that and yeah also one of the great
things I've talked about here is you can
actually use a temporal weighting scheme
that's a little more complex I didn't
have time to get into to cause it to
value recent information over past
information that lets it respond to
changes in the world better I've
actually seen promotions where someone
forgot to turn off a Thanksgiving
promotion where one was at a hundred
percent or ninety something percent for
a while the other was at one minus
ninety something percent and then they
swap so I think that really depends on
your marketing application sometimes not
running a power now a power analysis
will tell you that Navy test is
infeasible and this may make it
practical and somewhat valuable and
other times you can respond to the the
changes in the world that being said
there's a time and a place for a/b
testing like we have 10 years of
experience for a be testing these are
pools that have some overlap some
differences appropriate in lots of
different situations that I'm happy to
talk right we have tons of kind of
market or facing documentation when
should you do this when should you do
that it it's not so clear-cut that like
just use this always and for everything
so I think your I've kind of somewhat
answered and somewhat not answer to your
question they talked thanks very much
this actually has a cool application in
finance too and and so the stuff we've
in financial applications the
fundamental problem is that like user
people's preferences change so like you
know one month they like a blue button
another month like they like the green
button kind of thing so there's some way
of sort of introducing like a recency
bias into the whole yeah absolutely
there is if you shoot me an email I can
I can send you a paper from Microsoft
research that introduces kind of a
weighted version of Bayes theorem which
is what we actually implement underneath
so at every time step you allocate most
of your prior weight to the past prior
from the last time step and a little bit
to the no data prior so that in the
limit of no data it goes back to the no
data prior and our experience has shown
that that makes it much more susceptible
or much more reactive to changes in user
preferences so yeah this is kind of a
toy version of the system there are ways
to introduce recency bias and if you
shoot me an email I'm happy to send you
that paper thanks really interesting so
it seems like it's the the you were
talking about talking to marketers and
communicating this marketers it seems
like that's still like kind of a large
issue because basically you're asking
them kind of up front to like trust the
machine before like any sort of results
are kind of in how does that how does
that sort of like shake out yeah that's
a great question so some love it right
we have some clients that are trying to
scale tons of a/b tests if they have
tons of traffic and it's just hard for
people to keep track of so some of it
they'll delegate to this and they're
willing to take the risk that in
aggregate it turns out well for them and
some other ones we're introducing pure
user experience changes like saying okay
maybe wait five days before you jump and
before you start dynamically allocating
and show me what it would have been
doing to get over that problem
so that's something where we're putting
user experience guardrails that we know
are maybe not mathematically optimal to
drive adoption so I think it's a
combination of those things of finding
the people who are early adopters and
willing to use it and then while they're
while they're getting experience with it
iterating with other people and putting
in things you might believe to be
suboptimal to drive adoption right
because the point of math and industry
is to get it used right let's take the
speaker one more time
I'm happy to carry on the conversation
in the hallway